my first thought honestly because my
husband was off that day and we were all
driving home is that oh my god my house
is on fire and then I immediately
thought because the kids were in in
their car seats in the backseat that's
okay we're all safe the kids are here
we're safe it's okay
to me you know it was just a fire it can
all be replaced
on August 24 2012 in the Natomas
community of Sacramento the home of Brad
and Jennifer Taylor and their two
children was destroyed by fire
so this is our home
you can see the fire damaged everything
in here the front bathroom with our baby
toilet seat on it hey you're so raw
after it and realizing how much you lost
and uh and the things that can ever be
replaced little did the Taylor's know
that their problems were just beginning
so the fire happened on on Friday and
the following Thursday the insurance
adjuster came out with some contractors
to do a walk-through and work out bids
on what it would be to repair the damage
and during that process one of the
contractors mentioned about possibly
having to elevate the house in order to
rebuild it because we lived in Natomas
as the Taylor's found out due to FEMA
regulations implemented in 2008 they
would have to raise the habitable part
of their home 20 feet in order to
rebuild there were over 35,000 homes in
that area and never her elevated over 20
feet in the air and so to tell someone
that that's what they have to do to fix
their home which isn't covered by
insurance is ridiculous yeah would look
strange and folks have considered this
requirement to be a de facto moratorium
as what you've probably heard because
not many folks want to build up 20 feet
when the Taylor's bought their home in
1998 they thought they were making a
safe investment FEMA had just certified
the levies for a hundred years on in 98
and so we thought say purchasing here
they
move the requirement for mandatory flood
insurance at the time and we thought was
going to be a starter house and 14 years
later we were still in it for 2008
anatomists Basin was in an X zone which
allowed regular development allowed
regular reconstruction of homes and
prior to 2008 when Katrina happened
there was a heightened awareness to
flood prone areas so the federal
government reassessed different levees
and subsequently the Sacramento levees
were decertified and the area was
re-designated as an as an AE zone so we
were told by our mortgage company we
were told by FEMA that we had to get
flood insurance but that was pretty much
all that we were told what the Taylors
weren't told is that homes destroyed by
fire in AE zones can only be rebuilt if
they're raised to the base flood
elevation which for the Taylors means 20
feet otherwise new building and
renovations costing more than 50 percent
of the value of the structure are
prohibited the city has on record that
our home is just a structure alone that
our home is worth seventy one thousand
dollars so according to them we couldn't
spend more than thirty five thousand
dollars to fix her home the estimates to
repair our home are about a hundred and
ninety thousand or more hoping to find a
solution to their dilemma the Taylors
attempted to contact FEMA I called the
regional office many many times I had
written to the regional office many
times trying to even find a phone number
to contact anyone in FEMA is very very
difficult I have discovered we don't
have the authority to make land-use
decisions for a community the city of
Sacramento normally does have the
authority to make land-use decisions but
in this instance they're constrained by
FEMA regulations the city could provide
a variance but there again caught by our
guidance the the federal regulations
require that in order for us to
participate in the National Flood
Insurance Program and receive aid if a
flood were to happen we have to abide by
the rules
those federal rules have placed the
Taylor family in an enviable situation
we can you cannot use the property we
can't rebuild we can't sell it you know
because it's useless to anybody we still
have to pay for flood insurance on that
property we're also paying the mortgage
on the property the mortgage company
suggested that we walk away from the
launch neither one of us are ok with
that we believe if you had a
responsibility and so that
responsibility regardless of the
circumstances it's unpleasant and it's
not the mortgage company's fault any
more than it is ours probably the best
long-term solution to say it that way is
for Congress to provide the Corps of
Engineers the money to fix the levees
unfortunately for the Taylors FEMA's
long-term solution won't fix their
real-time problem so for now the
Taylor's must pin their hopes on
Congress carving out an exemption that
will finally free them from their
bureaucratic limbo Doris Matsui Sophos
has been very helpful congresswoman
Matsui has actually introduced a some
legislation to help change things if
passed the fire-damaged home rebuilding
act of 2012 would give FEMA the
authority to grant families like the
Taylors a variance that would allow them
to rebuild their home they got this bill
written very very quickly you know so
they're trying to do what they can
however you know even a congresswoman
has limited power and you know really
it's the constituents to have to put
pressure on their representatives to try
to get something like this changed I've
stuck Flyers under windshields we had we
extended stood in front of grocery
stores handing out fliers actually the
two days before Thanksgiving because
they were the busiest shopping days we
went out to the local grocery stores and
we're handing out flyers for hours and
hours and hours but if I were in the
same situation I would want to blame
someone quite honestly and it's easy to
blame government I feel terrible for
them you know she
has a family and they've been paying
their mortgage for 13 years it doesn't
always work out the way we Intendant but
we never stop trying if you're allowed
to buy here and you're allowed to live
here you should be allowed to rebuild
your home here